good
morning millennial swag caught me right
at the end of a yawn as we were three to
one in could have gone right into it do
you think do you think that yawns are
like a social construct well they are
contagious via social constructivist so
I had for one of my SAT sections a
reading section all about yawning which
was actually cruel and what it said was
like even the word yawn can make a
person you're on like I'm feeling like I
shitty on right now look it's like the
word lice can make your head itchy hmm
just talking about yawning can actually
make you yawn the word lice can make
your head itchy no I can't good morning
happy Friday
good morning everyone it's like 60
degrees in New York and if you're here
because he saw us on Access Hollywood
last night well oh yeah maybe we have
some new listeners who are trying to
keep themselves in tune with what's
necessary because our segment finally
aired on Access Hollywood last night
after much trial and tribulation and it
was worth the wait
what a flattering piece it was so cute
and fun and the lighting was just like
mmm it was really great and like while I
didn't love how I look I didn't even
care and even though they were using so
many fat photos of us I still didn't
care no I liked the way that I looked
but it really put a spotlight on how
much I talk with my hands
no but also they put footage from our
first episode to like the episode that
they were filming with Nick vile and the
amount that the show is changing that
we've changed is I could start without
the footage from the first episode you
know that wasn't my greatest day are set
wasn't really there yet it's it's
humbling you know and I get to know
where you come from we're coming up on
the one-year anniversary of the toast
well let's not forget you know that
first rough day because that's made this
success even sweeter well speaking of
rough days checking I wanted to send our
love to our New Zealand toasters what
it's literally a horrible day in New
Zealand and I feel like days in New
Zealand are always like lit and warm
right and it was last night when in Cape
Mike that's right yep any time
difference today when it happened
horrible terrorist attack a horrible
horrible story and to make it worse it
was all live streamed and I just I can't
live saw the footage it was going viral
on Twitter and I didn't know what
happened I was just scrolling on my
phone before bed and it looked like a
video game and I started to watch him
what the [ __ ] is this and I
and I got lucky huge pin my stomach and
then I looked at the hashtag and I read
a bunch of tweets about what was going
on but the time difference like news was
coming out slowly and I literally
couldn't sleep all night and I was just
like up with bed talking because I
couldn't get the picture out of my mind
it looks like a video game because I
don't nobody should watch it and I don't
even want to draw attention to it cuz
it's literally the most horrible thing
ever but it's like so inhumane and vile
and I accidentally watched it and then I
told everyone in the chatham I don't
watch it if you see it because I fell
into the trap well I'm sorry that you
saw it I'm sorry that it happened I'm
sorry to the hole it's horrible oh my
god nice Church it's horrible also
abusing cuz it's in Christchurch but it
was in a mosque right so I think it was
in church at first I think the town is
called tracers yeah cute yeah cute name
very sad and I think 49 people have been
confirmed dead so far twenty injured
which okay but the shooters still live
really yes and I have an idea
for him I say we livestream him and we
all get to like stab him or something
you love thinking about how you would
punish it's like the only thing that
makes me feel better in these situations
is like getting revenge but I think
what's so sad it's like you can think
about all of the different situations
and like nothing will ever bring justice
to the victims to their families no
matter how much you inflict pain on the
person like it's you know the damage is
done totally and it's really sad so our
thoughts are with everyone this morning
in New Zealand so not a great way to
start the day but besides that will
deliver the fast five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of your morning shows you
know was watching access like last night
and I was like really impressed with
their segways and I do think as hosts
that is one thing we could work on we
could work on but I think we do a pretty
good job and also when we don't do a
good job we're the first to call
ourselves out yeah or like if you do it
in a really abrupt way like sometimes
it's funny yeah yeah or sometimes it's
like that's what the news does they tell
the story they don't always work on
their segues they just you know
transition to a new lens so like I'll do
one lens right here at the past type
story oh yeah morning Millennials but
sometimes didn't even have to say
anything it's just a quick head tilt to
the ladies all decided we're moving on
from this I learned a lot from our
access piece last night much mostly that
it like a big turtle neck while you
think it's a cute look like you know he
looks cute I guess I kind of looked like
I had like a neck injury well I thought
it was really doesn't
he bites for my psyche when I say
mastectomy she was laughing that I said
I was standards at HR totally and that's
so true and they didn't remember what I
watched because like I was just so
excited I ran out of dinner like
literally ran down the block couldn't be
more excited Ben was like literally
still paying the check I was like I'll
meet you at home and I made it just in
time
really funny I guess it's part of their
new segment of girlboss content creators
and I'm really excited I think my time
in the first people I'm excited to see
who is featured among us GCU is that
coming on next week know your
doppelganger that YouTube little girl
who does ASMR shut up how funny is that
have to get her on the show I know I
love I've subscribed to her I subscribed
her to because I want to support her
unfortunately I'm not a fan of ASMR so
maybe the videos aren't for me but I
love when she goes viral with her little
memes of being a flight attention she's
so funny you really actually look a lot
like her no it's like when I have a
family it's gonna be her Noah Ritter
it's like my kid yep and then maybe I'll
get like a random blonde Mason Ramsey
like happened to Noah Ritter I don't I
hope he's just like in school getting
his education in a legal way and then
he'll pop back up when the time has come
yeah cuz it's hard to start so young not
everyone can be Mason Ramsey like a
social media team that is [ __ ] savage
totally you know what I thought of today
you know the clip that like has been
viral on Twitter for like years I'm the
queen and you're the sorry people that
kid who's like that lady comes to clean
out his fridge where is he now Oprah
should do like a update Ellen should do
an update when she brings all these kids
on her show like where are they now
yeah but Oprah does like a where they
know things right but with people on her
show well so I like Oprah better than
Ellen's I totally agree okay fine but
and I think Oprah would be kind these
kids are definitely in contract with
Ellen on Ellen yeah um also major life
update I wants to tell everyone I got my
second ear pierced my second told me I
got my second hole parsed um and I'm not
gonna lie it
everyone's like did it hurts it hurt it
did not hurt for a second like it was
really the most painless thing and
everyone's like you're not gonna get to
sleep it hurts I literally have
forgotten about it until right now I
just got like a little bit of a sting
which reminded me that I got my ear
piercing maybe might you're just wanting
me to talk about it okay well I don't
know what about it I got your ear
pierced sorry I may be your party Harty
hurting my feelings do I get like it's
like you're turning
you're back on your roots do I look like
I'm about to rob a bank or something no
honestly I feel like [ __ ] Joan Jett
do you yeah I didn't hurt because you're
the most dramatic I'm the most romantic
[ __ ] on the planet it didn't hurt at
all and now I want to get another one
but I was gonna get to last night but
apparently can only have one at a time
for like safety reasons fair could you
get could you have gotten your belly
button did you inquire yes I did I'm
Margot Lewin who works at the Allison
lose store where it was I was like I'm
gonna get my tongue pierced she's like
no you're not do they do that yes I
asked Mike if I wanted to come in here
and get like my [ __ ] pierced I could I
just liked it I hope they have different
machines and it was the same guy who
live Pierce parsed Jackie's ears on the
morning breath last year it was the same
guy but I don't think he remembered me
cuz I guy wasn't the one getting pierced
party he would remember this these years
and he was back to access because I just
can't say I just wanted to mention that
I can't believe I was on TV Jackie I say
didn't breathe same it's like whoever
edited that clip like what's definitely
a toaster was in tune with what's
necessary like it has the Oh been
impossible all day like ever since his
big break um yeah I mean he got back
from his walk like covered in mud and it
was just like when he does that and I'm
like getting ready to leave I just don't
have time to like take care of him do
you know right threw him in the tub but
he's a big star now so he that's not his
problem that's true you know yeah and
then also Nick Viall made it onto our
segment totally have you heard from him
I have not but someone should share the
clip with him because it's just so
flattering and cute and we our little
baskets made it too oh my god that is so
cute I love our basket he's also while
Nick vile was here he told me something
that really shook me to the core and I
think it's gonna shake you as well
because I was talking about his descent
oils which I truly have been loving he
was saying he's coming out with
diffusers of the essential oils material
so I was like cool you know material you
know what I mean I'm Lizzy essential
oils that's cool sounds cool I always
like a good smell and he was like most
people use candles I was like I love
candles I have the biggest candles the
prettiest candles the smelliest candles
and he was like but what you don't
realize this you're literally inhaling
not only smoke like when you're just
laying in bed and the candles go and
you're inhaling smoke but like it's like
perfumed
chem oh yeah loke and it just really got
me thinking about like sense and the
chemicals in them that we ingest and now
like
you know so now every time you put on
like a perfume do you feel like maybe
it's not good
well sometimes but it just able to pen
on situation I don't always inhale my
perfume but it could be great to go the
organic perfume route well even if you
spritz on perfume every day here's
something you might not think about
what's actually in it that's why we're
so excited about Fleur
they make stunning non-toxic perfumes
and list all their ingredients online
you get a good scent with clean
ingredients and the sample process is
just plain fun for luxurious perfume
that's all good clean fun trifler pH L
you are go to floor comm today use promo
code toast to get 20% off your first
custom Fleur sample set pick three cents
to try get credit towards a full-size
bottle of your favorite one that's promo
code toast at Fleur calm to get your
first three Fleur favored and says
samples at 20% off Fleur phlu art comm
code toast that's great and you know of
course Kourtney Kardashian's watching
like that's a great prime note actually
heard about it from her I mean it's
always nice like just be a little
organic sometimes I feel as if I'm
organic in my in my sense of humor
speaking of organic senses of humor I
have a ticket tip I wish I have a show
up Fox was this weekend I'm not even
shelling for tickets cuz you [ __ ]
sold that [ __ ] out so there's a couple
individual seats left they consider that
a sellout in my biz because like no
one's gonna buy a ticket like if they're
a group of people and get like three
separate tickets so Jackie's coming I'm
coming
we're making it apart yeah it's a scene
evaluation well they were extremely
generous Foxwoods just like ask me how
many rooms I needed and I just randomly
said excuse me six even though I know
like four people so I'm just inviting
everybody everyone at the parsing party
I'm just inviting people you need a room
you let me know I'll take care of it me
too I've never been I've never been to
Foxwoods say what you gonna hear
something so funny so I invited your
friend Margo she said okay I'm gonna
come I've never been to AC before I'm
like hmm I don't know tell you this it's
not in Atlantic City but I just thought
it was cuz it's like a casino near New
York you know it's yeah but it's like
it's it's like if you just went to the
Borgata like there's nothing else right
you don't leave the resort so same thing
but it's like weirdly in Connecticut
like we're just gonna be like ladies
with our pearls I'm gonna have to take
out my second hearing you can't wear two
earrings in Connecticut you can wear two
earrings at Foxwoods oh sure I don't
there's no get out of the car before
Foxwoods your [ __ ] you like if we do
it's gonna be New Jersey or something
it's so funny okay well I feel pretty
caught up anything else we're gonna do
to your toasters at the end of the show
yes we are
I feel pretty caught up on my personal
life anything you want to share with the
group Oh regarding my personal I know
I'm pretty good you know just out here
along chug in I don't know like I wear
the voice okay I'm so sore Oh big
mistake big mistake huge still looking
for an apartment just you know in the
exciting time there's also so much good
news today that I really felt like um
overwhelmed so I'd like to hop to it if
you don't feel overwhelmed and you don't
feel under around can you ever just feel
whelmed here are the fast five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast first story the iHeartRadio Music
Awards were on last night on a Thursday
night which is really weird and what's
even weirder as they pulled the biggest
names in the music industry notably
Taylor Swift and I have a ladder I gotta
even though she didn't show up neither
did cardi B but they made it seem like
all these people are gonna be there but
then another day no one was there except
Taylor Swift was there which is like
bigger than anything I have a lot of
thoughts about the iHeartRadio Music
Awards airing on a Thursday in general
because I have to say like I love them I
enjoyed them too and I think the artists
really enjoy them because like it's not
the Grammys so it's like you can
literally tell you know the person that
I heart like you have so much control if
I don't put the camera on me
now I don't want to stay for the whole
show I'm going to talk about mentioned I
would like my initiatives in Africa
mentioned like you can you can shell
your own products I like this award I'm
working with this sponsor I would like
Taco Bell to paint me I think if you
agree to go and you're a big name
they'll pretty much give you whatever
you want which is how it's remained
successful they also were like one of
the only shows that like really I don't
know like gives in to the Millennials
not even the money was the Jen's ears
you know like there were so many people
there like I had no idea they were like
love yeah because it's oh I know love
love um because it's interesting but
then at the end of the day it's like
they control the radio so the big
artists do you want to play right then
because I want my songs and the beer in
bed if you have a good relationship with
IR radio like your songs good or bad
totally on the radio that's true that's
true no I was actually really surprised
cause I'm always making fun of IR radio
they have like fake podcasts I'm like
everything they do is take their like
their didn't they declare bankruptcy as
a company I got media but they literally
had a billion dollar award show like I
don't get the company whatsoever but I
happen to have really liked and enjoy
the show because it wasn't that serious
I loved t-pain I loved t-pain as well
and he won the mass singer which I
Creole II swept I don't even know the
world I everyone was talking about in
like all of the who the people were were
like so concealed even when they
revealed themselves it's like any time I
got a news alert they wouldn't put it in
a headline because it was like so like
potato protected and I just think it's
like I didn't watch my singer but I
enjoyed that other people enjoyed it you
know ya know I just thought - you paint
like didn't take himself too seriously
like it was being really funny I loved I
loved the Alicia Keys of it all I loved
was she's like coming back I love how
she doesn't wear makeup anywhere or do
her hair like I just love her then she
was wearing the glittery eye shadow and
it wasn't even like I'm in a makeup well
it was in like a fashion way it was like
a decorative yeah I don't think it was
glitter eye shadow I think it was like
moisturizer
no she was wearing silver eyeshadow when
she was playing at the piano but it's
like it she was yeah but she also wasn't
wearing skin makeup like I think her
point about not wearing makeup is like
we don't have to like pretend to be
someone else someone else Arbeit more or
less beautiful than we are like we're
beautiful the way that we are but like
if I want to wear like silver eyeshadow
cuz it matches my dress like that's not
conflicting with her mess it's an
accessory
yes it's like wearing a pair of earrings
totally that's a good point well I just
loved her relationship with Taylor like
the three amigos her Maren and Taylor
and in her speech she gave Taylor Maren
to shout outs yeah and also like the
only like people who showed up to the
show
we're Taylor Maren and I used to work at
iHeartRadio so I can confirm that a lot
of what they do is fake but a lot of
what they do is good and fun and cute oh
my god I totally forgot that you sort
they're right I once did the Jingle Ball
did you ever like decide anything
what do you mean like an NDA now I can
tell us everything I could tell you
whatever you wanted to know but I feel
like you weren't privy to really you
know good information level information
no and like I work sound like social
stuff so that's always fun and they have
good social media presidents and their
snapchat channel is always like cute
when I used to watch it so I mean yeah
and they do a good a festival show but
it is like pretty fake and then they
bring everyone from The Bachelor and
it's like Hannah gee all of a sudden
gets as many cameras it's Taylor Swift
totally she was sitting two rows
lawndale's I know but honestly she
deserves it and she beautiful better
timing she's beautiful she looked
beautiful and that was like her first
year override part because she hasn't
been able to
yeah also I really enjoy the iron radio
Awards because they gave an homage I
don't know if that's story word but the
you didn't - my my one and only true
love's 5 seconds of summer they got like
a proper American introduction and I
learned a lot about them I'm such a big
fan of theirs but I don't even know they
started on YouTube I didn't know that 9
was it by YouTube they said on the thing
last night I didn't know that either and
they're just like a couple kids from
Australia who just love rock music
that's really good yeah and I just love
I love them and I love their love for
like their work do you know what I mean
yeah they're like proud of their songs
yeah and they're like also proud to like
not be like the one most popular one
direction they're like very much in
their category of Roth they don't stray
from that they're like they have branded
themselves as like The Simple Plan for
Millennials and they don't change their
music to like become more like z100 you
know right but then they inadvertently
are z100 because they have it confusing
that there's a song called Youngblood
and there's an artist called gay Jackie
I couldn't agree on you know it's things
like that that makes me feel old yes
because when when I saw Youngblood was
performing I was like Youngblood I think
there's a different spelling oh did you
fortnight in your room I think I was 14
anyway room much like Alicia Keys son
doing the flaws oh my god she's okie
really good job he's putting the piano
he's really talented she just was like
very well-behaved children she does I
mean she seems like she would be an
incredible mother no totally I was just
loving necessarily and it's like her
kids will get into college based on
their based on their marriage yeah
totally okay but the story is Taylor
Swift shuts down haters with empowering
speech at the 2019 iHeartRadio Music
Awards the 29 year old popstar took the
stage at the 2019 I hurt Radio Music
Awards as she received one of the
highest honors at the star-studded event
the songstress is used to winning awards
for her musical talents however this one
in particular holds a special meaning
before taking to the stage to accept her
award which was presented by fellow
musician of brand Maren Morris the star
gushes over the highlight videos
displayed on the big screen
earning the coveted tour of the Year
award for her reputation to her
achievements the singer-songwriter gives
an emotional acceptance speech quote one
of the most wonderful things about the
way that this whole tour turned out is
that like for the entire six months
leading up to the first show of his tour
every headline that I read was this is
going to be a massive failure she says
holding her award she continues and it
really did wonders for my self-esteem
it was really great to hear people
saying that I was going to be playing to
nearly half empty stadiums honestly I
remember reading it and I mean she
reported that on the show bizz New York
Post it's a page 6 article and it says
sales for Taylor Swift North America
tour are set to be her worst yet or so
yeah and as she will be paying to empty
see ya quote I've learned a lot one of
the things I've learned is that life is
really unpredictable and people can make
forecasts and they can make predictions
but those predictions and forecasts may
not come true if there's an
unforeseeable factor involved and that
unforeseeable factor in this case was my
fans I honestly Oh everything everything
in my life to you honestly I really I
this was a great speech and I related to
it on a personal level me too and you
know I didn't realize until right now
that like when the whole snake Kim Kanye
thing happened like that was her worst
woman her whole world shattered she went
into hiding she finally released an
album and then I guess when she released
a ticket to uh tour tickets sales were a
little slow do you think she thought
like for a moment there like it was the
end cuz like the one thing she's always
been able to do is like sell music and
sell tickets no I don't think she
thought it was the end because she'd
just released reputation so the album
did really well I think she knew that
the fans were there but honest thing
that gets hard to get tickets to a
Taylor Swift show ah I don't know I
wonder how do those people buy tickets
cuz like I wait til the day before and
buy the one stuff up right I either have
an alert for when pre-sales going live
and like a toaster will give me a code
and I'm the first one to buy a ticket
and like I got a pretty decent seat for
the best price or I do it the day before
or I get free seats sometimes if I'm
right if I'm trying to thirst if it's a
country concert I'll thirst with the
publicist but I'm just wondering how
does so much already if people get
tickets do they do the whole like
Ticketmaster thing um I think they do
the second master thing like Dana
doesn't goes to a lot of concerts and
she's a pretty prudent gal so she'll get
tickets when they go live or she'll be
like scouting for tickets like you have
to remember to keep check right and I've
done that for like a lot of the shows of
people that I love like my Kelly
Clarkson tickets and my Kacey Musgraves
tickets I think I was like part of the
first day though buying tickets also if
you listen to artists on Spotify very
early in their career you get presale
code yeah and then Spotify emails you
and I've gotten a lot of tickets that's
like crazy like they like track you I
know but it's like okay at least to
music okay I understand everyone takes
your information and they sell it but if
you're gonna do all that just at least
like give me something give me a little
good like yes sir
all of my ads for like shopping sites
that usually it's like targeted ads
based on things you've read II looked at
it's like I either bought it or I
decided I didn't want it so stop serving
me things that I've already looked at
it's really annoying when they serve you
think it's like you already purchase
what I think you need two pairs of boots
no it's annoying but yesterday I was
getting stuff that I've never seen
before that was like my style so I don't
know who's doing my targeted ads but you
were on point
actually it's really weird because I was
getting targeted ads for like cute
Coachella looks literally two days after
we decided that we might go to Coachella
that's weird
I mean jacker like the Antichrist when
it comes to Coachella but we try and
remain the epicenter of all things cool
and fun and unfortunately that means we
might have to go to Coachella it's a
struggle for us it's a constant struggle
it's a constant struggle because the
treacherous and like I just feel like as
a chubby person like Coachella is just
not that like chubby friendly it's a lot
of walking there's a lot of you know
situations for chub-rub and I do feel as
if I do if I am gonna go like I am gonna
have to like get my looks together and
get my body snatched because it's just
not it's not an environment that's like
Claudia friendly you know you're less
chubby than you were the last time we
that's true it can only be easier if you
think about it right and we would be
going now because like you know brand
partnerships are buried lucrative at
Coachella and where's my business women
totally speaking inbred partnerships one
thing I want to try before Coachella if
would you decide to go I'm on noon and I
do think that it is the one thing that
might actually be able to get this
sister snaps I think that it well
because I've been on it and I've been
enjoying it I really it's the Teddy
Mellencamp of apps oh my god that's hold
you accountable yeah I don't want to eat
this thing or not work out because then
I have to tell noon no totally it's like
when you had a bad test great enough to
like bring it to get a signature to your
parents mm-hmm so weight loss is in the
palm of your hand literally with new on
your phone whenever and wherever you
need it we're all strapped for time but
noon just asks you to commit 10 minutes
a day to you I think I can do that with
new mule have a personalized training
and with your own support team for less
than the price of a single appointment
with a nutritionist or a personal
trainer you get a goal specialist it's a
behavior change professional nutritional
expert and fitness trainer and a
community that's there for you
much like the morning toast your
discussions with fellow new members to
keep you encouraged numa's design for
results it's out with the old habits in
with the new sign up for your trial
today at noon calm / toast that's
n-o-o-o m.com / toast what do you have
to lose for me a lot
at noon calm / chose to start your trial
today
perfect can you imagine like a psycho
cello again when we went last time we
swore we were like we're never gonna go
we swore and it was Treach Ella and it
was like awful but it was also really
great we had a really fun time we need
so many memories we made so many friends
we actually did make a lot of friends
and good it was great for the big
connections yeah just started to show
two weeks before and it was really good
to like get ourselves out there and I
feel like now and I mean as an like now
you the whole brand ecosystem like
working with brands and revolve of it
all and blah blah blah it's like it's
not like you're just going to a festival
no and but also ariana grande keeps
warming so it's much more Seanie vibes
then it was then and I think now that
we've been once we know a few uhm like
shortcuts when it comes to removing
treacherous and it's like I will not
refuse to go to the festival like
anytime before 6 o'clock like Suns down
then I go and that's when most people go
and I need to get the special parking
pass so that we can just drive right up
and I don't have to walk that long
desert road yeah I will be working on
the parking pass and that's my job great
also I wanted to talk about Taylor Swift
speech because not only did I relate to
it on personal above like everyone
telling you that you're nothing and then
they don't realize the power of your
fans the toasters I just like felt that
to my core but also she is a toaster
mitts could she listened to our episode
of the toast of our big fight where I
said Taylor Swift was treating her
Instagram like The DaVinci Code and her
fans are like [ __ ] Nicolas Cage in
national treasure trying to figure it
out and she alluded to that she was like
I love that you guys are so passionate
about the work and she pretty much said
there's new music you'll be the first to
know stop looking at my Instagram for
codes and I and I so appreciated
I felt seen and then I felt heard well I
felt disappointed because to be honest I
thought the only reason she was really
showing up to farce of an award show was
to do something special like perform no
but she did give more clues and more
overt heavy handed well here why I know
she said you'll be the first to know
like you shut up but then I also thought
it was good the first April first I
don't know I'm just thinking do you see
that thread in the toasters of everyone
making fun of dissecting her posts
there's 87 spots on this photo her
albums coming out in 87 days palm trees
seven letters eight letters that means
album
coming out an eighth date guys just it
gives a it's something to do while
there's no Taylor music sorry but she
has she's now being heavy handed in some
of the vibes that she's the butterfly
motif the butterfly motif which I don't
know how much I'm feeling considering
like okay I know a lot of people have
done butterflies before but right now
Kacey Musgraves is in a butterfly stage
and it is still happening so I don't
care I'm just so happy that we're out of
like that dark snake black leathers
crimson lip and it's very clean II it's
positive happy like go Aries she's so
happy she's loved she's not being tied
down by her reputation she's free and
her outfit last I didn't know that you
loved it and I thought it was really
cute for Kesha five years ago with no it
was cute I just I think it's
representative of the new phase were
going into which is my very happy
butterfly mare mermaid legs legs legs
pink hair loved it the pink Eric to me
was an interesting choice but you know
what she never makes interesting choices
she's always playing it safe so for that
reason I give a gold star and you know I
just give a gold star because I like
anything she does and I'll never say
anything bad about her that and I own
that and you can beat that way but I'm
gonna I'm gonna Teddy melon cameraman
hold our jug you're gonna be a Katie
Maloney you're gonna call it as I see it
I'm gonna call it as I see it and I just
went like and I will also give
allowances based on like you know who
she's been in the past and I want to say
like I like where this is all headed and
I'm excited for her also as much as
she's so calculated and I shouldn't sure
they got her radio words were like ready
to do whatever to have her walk on the
carpet like there was an awkward moment
where TP made a joke about her and she
didn't know how to react with the boobs
so I was just like weird and given like
her being like a an advocate for like
sexual assault victims and I just
thought it was a really weird joke I
couldn't agree more and is a weird joke
on his part and then she didn't know in
that moment she had to do like years
worth of PR research to figure out how
to react and it's like at first she
wants to be cool and go along with it
but then she's wait this goes against
everything I've been preaching for but
wait am I gonna be a [ __ ] at this award
later she didn't know and then she was
just like this like it was have a face
it was really awkward yeah it was that
word I don't think she's I think like
after the actually had a bit I did you
okay it was a weird joke it was a weird
joke for a million different and it's
like what there's no correct reaction I
see the picture on your iPad and I know
what the story isn't it's so sad it's so
sad and it's all so we'll get to it
Louis Louie I don't know Louie Tomlinson
sister felicity
Tomlinson dead at 18 Louie Tomlinson's
younger sister Felicity and that's how
her name is spelled Tomlinson has been
found dead at the age of 18
Felicity a model and social-media
influencer with over 1.3 million
Instagram followers reportedly collapsed
on Wednesday after a specific suspected
heart attack at her apartment in London
the Metropolitan Police Service tells
enews that police were called by London
Ambulance Service on Wednesday to a
residential address following reports of
a female and cardiac arrest
officers attended and a female believed
to be age 18 was pronounced dead at the
scene
police aren't in the process of
informing her next of kin the statement
reads from police at this stage the
death is being treated as unexplained
the post-mortem examination will take
place in due course this is really sad
and it's also not the first story of a
young woman dying of a heart attack this
week well it's really sad also because
his mom just died too so like and he was
like so heartbroken about his mom and
like all the One Direction members like
got together just except for saying to
like you know rally around him because I
think he was like super devastated by it
and now it's just like oh my god
this is the worst thing that could
happen after the worst thing that
already could happen happened you know
yeah this is a tough time what's the
other situation
Miss Teen Universe my god yes was also
pronounced dead I think it was not more
than a week ago from Harvard yeah yeah
so weird so weird and sad and scary and
I mean 18 year olds dying from heart
attack is not a normal thing so perhaps
there's something else going on uh
either you know I don't know what the
word is but you know it could be an
existing issue because people do have
heart issues right or you know added
factors as well so I just read an
interesting article it was an interview
with Louis Tomlinson
but right before this talking about like
his relationships with the One Direction
man bandmates and how like he was ready
on the outs with Zayn but when his mom
died like everyone really came for him
except for Zayn and I'm just curious to
know like how the boys are rallying
around him again and I'm just I'm always
keeping my eye out for the One Direction
reunion so I'm just wondering how this
is gonna affect it I think the same
people will be there for him we don't
and when did his mom pass away like a
year ago
laughs well unless he's made amends with
Zayn I don't think we can expect him to
come around this is so sad I'm like
she's so getting pretty so cute if he
says yeah
sister who's an influencer I don't know
Lottie Lottie I'm pretty sure he has a
sister who's like a big big beauty
influencer but then apparently she's a
medium for two Lottie Tomlinson will you
kill her ello TI l OTT ie maybe I know I
think pretty sure she's a sibling up one
direction Lottie
emmalin's in this case it's just like
Charlotte Tomlinson yeah oh she but she
calls herself laddie oh yeah you're
right you're right 3.3 million followers
mm-hmm
so he just like gave hers to his whole
family totally oh my god that she's so
pretty yeah she sure they're sisters I'm
pretty sure cuz I followed her for a
long time based on the fact that she was
his sister yeah you're right you're
right you right you right interesting
siblings Lewis and Felicity felicity
yeah you're right
so it's really sad for both event oh my
god so sad well at least he has someone
I thought it was just him his mom and
his sister you know he has another
sister okay that's good yeah so sad like
I feel like he's such a nice boy I do
too and I feel like he's also like sadly
like a really family-oriented boy agreed
like his whole family has careers
because of a great big one and like he
kept in touch through the fame and the
fortune you know that documentary about
one direction where they where like on
like their fourth tour in a row with
like releasing an album recording the
album why there while they're on their
previous tour then the second this tour
is over releasing album never going home
and it had a lot to do with like their
relationships with their families it's
actually a really good documentary it is
a good document and this seems to me a
theme with all like music biopics or
documentaries where it's like album tour
album tour and they get really burnt out
and I just watched the Amy Winehouse
documentary and it is just like so
tragic but it's like the music industry
demands that like they're like we wanted
the next to write the record label it's
like we want the album now and it said
wouldn't you rather have a band with a
30 year career with this with a ton like
a huge discography as opposed to like a
band with five years of like a ton of
music that they just churned out right
that a hundred percent and she like back
to back was like her biggest album right
he's record smashing but she wrote it in
the worst time of her life and then she
gets into a better place
but now she has to tour that album and
sing those songs but so dancing it's so
depressing and she couldn't do it
anymore
well well Taylor Swift says a lot is
that she writes these songs about
painful moments and then every time she
sings her song it like is associated
with that painful moment but then when
she gets to do it on tour she no longer
associates you know that song with the
painful moment she's associated with
that great crowd in New Zealand or
whatever you know but I think that a lot
of what Taylor Swift singing on it's
like Jake Gyllenhaal never got together
it's a little more catchy then like Amy
why no I disagree any Winehouse his
breakup of a man who addicted to her to
drug oh my god but Taylor Swift is the
most dramatic like you can't just
because her songs are more like poppy no
but I mean the pain isn't as real I
think some of the heartbreaks that she
sings about not all of them because some
of them are deep in real but like
they're not as deep of Love's no I think
Amy Winehouse is just a whole lot was a
whole lot more unstable like I think
Taylor Swift like comes from this room
like like her mom goes on tour with her
like she she's able to compartmentalize
more and she doesn't do drugs whereas
like Amy Winehouse
was a little bit of a mess and not
necessarily had like the most stable
upbringing so she it wasn't it was easy
for her to get like kept you know
getting taken away by them by the lyrics
yeah okay that's that's fair also
everyone is commenting that Lahti is a
really cute name for Charlotte and they
totally agree like I wouldn't realize
Charlotte I need to write that down
totally your names I love names that
have built-in nicknames me too like I
love that my name is Jacqueline but
everyone calls me Jackie okay but like I
know you like the name babe but would
you ever name you keep Barbara no and
that's why I love the name babe for a
kid and I'd loved it for a really long
time but I don't have the the larger
name that you apply to college with I
always said like Jacqueline I applied to
college and maybe if my name is Jackie I
wouldn't have gotten in maybe because
Jackie like sounds kind of crazy and
wacky and maybe I would have had to
bribe someone maybe you'd be wacky
Jackie that's what they call you around
campus
oh yeah maybe I would have had to bribe
someone like boy like me who and we got
another story about Lori Loughlin I mean
it's an update on the update what handle
she has been dropped by hallmark oh yeah
so now it kind of the leachate has been
dropped by sephora princess Polly what's
princess Polly I have no idea I thought
it was weird that they had to it like
announced that they'd dropped her like
nobody even knows who you are
they're like cashing in on the press
Sephora
Tresemme hp8 what oh really she had a
commercial on TV with her mom mm-hmm and
hallmark for Lori Loughlin like this is
now it's like day three where the
brand's come and I actually oh it was on
Access Hollywood where they started
talking about it a little bit before us
and they made a really interesting point
and they had like a legal expert their
version of the Lisa bloom and what he
said was like this is gonna affect Lori
so much more than Felicity Huffman cuz
Felicity Huffman has always played these
like like that villainy but like more
edgy roles we're like and she doesn't
have like a corporation to lean on
whereas now Lori Loughlin has like had
secured herself as like America's
Sweetheart she's am Becky Full House
home our channel smile happy Christmas
when calls the heart so like her and her
family are much more beholden to
corporations and it's gonna affect them
that much more words like Felicity
Huffman has never pretended to be
anything other than Lynette Scavo right
and let's and this is on Bradford
Lynette Scavo no I mean Lynette Scavo
did do this with her twins right that's
a very good point
also they mentioned on Access Hollywood
that um this obviously the case has to
go to trial and people have to be tried
and they could be innocent or guilty and
if they are proven innocent
they can sue these brands and these like
Maury Lachlan could sue hallmark for
wrongful termination yeah I mean that's
like best-case scenario for them because
it's definitely true right but and I
think empires having the same issue with
Jesse smaller because if he gets fired
and is proven innocent but he hasn't
been laying off the show before so they
it's no he wasn't I think that was that
came out to be not true he just wanted
more money uh-oh uh-oh so he was just
Thursday okay yes seems like you know
not a big deal to throw your life away
for but it also seems like the brands
are choosing okay we'd rather take the
lawsuit down the line than deal with you
know the people on Twitter with their
pitchforks right well okay um would add
one more thought about this oh I mean
and my question is still out there where
are the mug shots right now it's weird
I've been reading the comments yesterday
and it seems like people not only don't
arrest it but they've also been released
on bail so like they really were injured
booked I don't know it's weird it is
weird also Laurie Lachlan starters have
dropped out of USC after the scam right
people were like are they gonna as USC
gonna kick him out as he gonna kick him
out they're like nah [ __ ] [ __ ] you I'm
out of here right because they couldn't
like deal with the bullying I mean I
mean just
because the older one I think was was a
graduate this year and then it really is
all for nothing right so now it's like
he went to all this trouble spend all
this money and like now it's really for
nothing personally I would have seen
really I don't know if I could I said
not if I were Olivia Jade except now she
kind of does need College because like
her career is in a lull but I do think
that there is possibility that she can
depending on what she's made up well
here so what the Access Hollywood guy
said was actually very interesting he
was like the the host was like do you
think this is gonna affect their careers
like are they done and he was like well
for Lori Loughlin like maybe but you
know for Olivia Jade like she's a super
young audience they tend to like like
controversy and her audience and her
base it might grow from this that's what
they said yes now she everyone like the
people who are writing up Olivia Jade
never wrote her up before she was
getting so much exposure and now
okay who's Olivia Jade let me go look at
her video right she's she's pretty right
and if you confer if you can forgive the
scandal and if you if it does come out
that they did not know then they're not
complicit in this well I think here's my
theory it's like they they knew you know
she knew she wasn't on the crew team or
whatever but it's like when your mom is
telling you to do something you just
think it's right right like if my mom
says it's okay look whatever and yes
maybe it's not by the book but that
doesn't mean it's a felony you know I
don't think when you're taking a fake
picture you're never seeing you're
committing a felony right people on
Instagram take fake pictures all the
time of trips they didn't go on ya know
like the hotels they didn't stay adults
in the situation like knew very well
what was going on but I just think when
you're a kid and like your mom tells you
to do something you automatically assume
it's okay and that it's the right thing
to do cuz like my mom won't let me do
something bad you know right so I just
think like it's an interesting position
for the kids it is and I think it'll I
don't think I think the jury is still
out on on how we treat them obviously
you know the media is so excited to take
them down which makes me less excited
because I just think it's a sad state of
the world well you know what the huffman
kids are just probably loving the fact
that like Olivia Jade has a YouTube
channel because everyone's really
fixated he's the face of this she's the
face of it cuz she's like this beautiful
girl she's a beautiful face of this and
the huffman kids like nobody knows where
they are I don't even know if they're
lost names Huffman
is it Gallagher I don't know is it Scavo
so they're probably just like so
grateful for the eliminated of them cuz
she's really taking a breath
well for anything right now no I mean in
a situation like this you you take your
blessings and you count them right so
anyways I would have I would have stayed
at school if I were Bella half a
semester keep your head down do your
homework get good grades and get the
[ __ ] out of there and get a degree
well yeah enough I wonder if they're
gonna enlist maybe in the University of
Phoenix I could do it from home they
could you know they don't have to deal
in bulletins and just one more residual
from this and I'm sure we'll expect more
as Stanford students are the first to
sue College is named in the admission
sandal so the thirst monsters have come
out to play for college students plus
parents of three of them have filed a
class-action suit against the college's
wrapped up in a nationwide emissions
scandal plus the scheme's mastermind
claiming that the plot denied them a
fair shot at entry to elite institutions
well there's one that makes sense to me
but there's one case Sanford there are
students suing their schools because now
their degrees aren't worth as much oh my
god this country is still litigious I
can't like okay so they're just for
random students why do they have more of
a case than any other student because
they're just they're getting in on it
well no this is a separate case I guess
there's the students claim that their
applications were undercut by William
Rick singers plot to fraudulently get
undeserving kids into top schools in
exchange for bribes from their
well-heeled parents damn I should have
applied to Yale and not gotten in and
been and then it's sued right now the
kids who had who have a case here are
the really smart hard-working kids with
4.0 GPS from maybe not a great part of
the country who didn't have access or
didn't have the opportunities to you
know meet a William Scavo whatever his
name is like those kids have a case here
not the [ __ ] who actually got in and
graduated but now my G curry is not
worth it
yeah losers yeah those are the third
monsters and I and I I'm here for people
I mean you have to prove that like you
were literally the number one on the
wait list and when your spot went to the
fact that you can sue anyone in this
country for anything is mind boggling
and I just want to say like I have a
case against the hunt and fish club
restaurant in New York and I never see
but like I was seriously injured in
their muster and trees really slippery
and there's scare
get in is really seen No ok ready ready
I have a case but I never took it out
but maybe I will because now everyone's
getting lawyered up
ready ok I was walking in to a meeting
that I was early for so she said the
person's on here yet it was very hot in
the restaurant I'm like ok lady I'm
gonna wait outside and I was on the
phone with that so in New York in the
wintertime like the front door to a a
restaurant has like a an extra door it's
like they make this little alcove out of
like plastic so that like the wind
doesn't get into the restaurant so I
opened the door the real door then I'm
in the little alcove I open the alcove
door and you think once you're on the
alcove you're on the street you're
basically outside right so I open that
door and I step out to what I think is
the street nope it was a huge step went
the lying like full face on the ground
people on the street were like is she ok
like I was mortified and the best part
was that been heard the whole audio so
he said this is what I did it was
horrifying people from the restaurant
like out here like literally ready to
call it a dance it was the biggest step
I thought onto the concrete like I was
sofa clamp to my person my jacket my
hair like her vine thank God the person
that I was meeting with like wasn't
there yet because like I couldn't have
been able like I would've had to go home
horrible nothing's worse than mine your
knees hit the ground and I have a case
yeah I got like scraped palms and knees
it was really embarrassing I'm so sorry
that that happened to you I have a case
people are saying that Bella is the
sophomore oh never mind I don't know
where it made up normal to me the ISIS I
saw that that I saw them in a few places
she just had half a semester lesson I
guess that makes the story more
interesting yeah cuz as a sophomore
that's a three more years of of
awkwardness you know what now you're
right I feel like they're closer in age
I mean they are I'm pretty sure they're
just one year apart yeah okay that makes
more sense
so so lesson learned
I'm gonna sue huntin fish okay and now
if anyone is a lawyer I need Toledo and
Barnes
they don't pay unless you get paid oh I
mean I think the statute of limitation
has run out on your case and you don't
have any proven injuries you didn't call
anyone you think
go to a doctor I should have taken
pictures of my injuries you're right
yeah I think it's always next go back in
the winter yeah okay done
but Natalie will delete the upside I
also each school now has existing
students who were part of the scandal
and so what do you what do you like USC
hadn't made a decision about Bella and
Olivia they made the decision for
themselves what do you think about the
students who are in school right now I
don't know I think it should be a
case-by-case situation like if your GPA
is over a three oh you can stay okay
that's fair yeah that's like it depends
on the school like if it's Harvard it's
35 mm 303 OS is a good grade whatever it
is that you need in order to like rush
or something whatever we set the
standard at then you can stay okay I
don't know I don't know what the right
thing to do is like I guess the right
thing to do is is kick him out but like
I said the real tragedy here is the kids
who weren't able to go to them so that
doesn't fix that problem
yeah no no because it's a gun less you
couldn't replace find the most qualified
student from that year who didn't get in
and replace I'm like you know honestly
that shouldn't be so hard yeah they have
everything on files yeah
that's the good fix yeah but they're
already in school somewhere else and you
know everything happens for a reason so
showing where they are and they're like
Leon I didn't get into Yale because I
just love the University of Phoenix
right
okay next story some drama in the
hosting world that we're not a part of
unfortunately Howard Stern and Wendy
Williams are going at it oh [ __ ] now I
don't know whose sides to take I know
it's a war of the media personalities
Howard Stern dedicated a generous
portion of a Sirius XM radio show on
Wednesday - slamming Wendy Williams
after she criticized his softer tone in
his new book Howard Stern comes again oh
she came from she came from first she
said pretty he has a new book and she
said and he's gone Hollywood now like
it's you know he's on yachts with all
these people like it's not interesting
he's not what he used to be oh so she
came for him she came for him so he said
Oh God
I guess it was a 30-minute ran jealous
[ __ ] but wait I just have to say like
there's in the current like in this past
month there are so many rumors swirling
around about Wendy Williams like she
really should just like not come for
people so much because now they're gonna
come for
and there's a ton of material right look
about our husband there's just a lot of
rumors swirling so I just think it was a
bad decision on her part
I'm sorry continue jealous [ __ ] you're
nobody to me the 65 year old shock jock
said you'll never be me Wendy you'll
never be me you can pretend to be me you
can pretend to be like me but you're not
you don't have my wit and you don't have
my talent you couldn't have that career
you're a fly the spat started when
Williams discussed Aaron's forthcoming
book she said Howard is so Hollywood
right now and Howard I love you but
since you've gone Hollywood everything
you say is so predictable every story is
going to be about oh I love this one and
then we went on their yacht he's a
Hollywood insider which sucks you
started like me being of the people but
at some point you sat behind the
microphone for too long and now you are
the people upon hearing Williams
sentiments however certainly
unpredictable Stern fired back claiming
it was Williams who had in fact gone
Hollywood what he said what evidence do
you have that I'm Hollywood honey I grew
up a scumbag and I'm just still treated
like a scotch oh boy I love it I'm
talking like Howard Stern what because I
found success now I'm with Hollywood
what cuz I know Jimmy Kimmel who am i
hanging out with she doesn't know who
I'm hanging out with she doesn't know
what I do in this world she doesn't know
who I'm [ __ ] with all she talks on
that show is about Hollywood
that's as Hollywood as you get are we
Hollywood know anybody Hollywood called
her to hang out she'd be there in two
seconds totally like I don't know I mean
it's so funny how they're using this as
an insult I'm like go Hollywood I would
love to like are you kidding I wish
someone would [ __ ] say that I'm
having at that Claudia she what's so
Hollywood like please so I think it's a
funny
it's a funny argument like that this is
what they're fighting about and it's
true like they both really got so
successful because they're super
relatable like when he keeps it real I'm
like Howard just like says anything he
wants like he doesn't give a [ __ ] who
he's talking to and I feel like they
both definitely maintain that level of
relatability but they both also have
their Hollywood moments I would say
probably Wendy more than Howard you
would think that I think it's also
because we're more familiar with Wendy
than we are I don't know I don't follow
Howard an Instagram I don't know what he
does with his I know but this is like on
Wednesday we show Wendy mysteriously
disappearing for three months and then
also just like coming back and like
lying about why she disappeared like
that's that's quite mysterious and quite
Hollywood this is what he said what have
I done to this woman nothing I've been
gracious to her worry about your husband
not me who [ __ ] you and your dumb show
and your mystery illness she disappears
she disappears for two months nobody
knows why and now she's questioning me
thanks honey
I never fainted on my show either oh my
god I know somebody you want to [ __ ] I
feel bad laughing like but it's honestly
a good stocking and you know what like
this was like I don't know like I feel
like this is the way that I feel like
anytime there's a situation where like
someone has tweets or like someone's
being accused of something like I am
trepidatious because you're like you
could throw that right back in my face
like I'm self-aware and Wendie out here
like coming for people when like her
when coming from the coming for the
biggest savage of them all right
especially when right now you're quite
vulnerable like I just think this was a
big mistake yeah he said I'm not
somebody you want to [ __ ] with honey I
don't want to hear your [ __ ] and
you're not a nice person nobody likes
you that's why you can't go Hollywood Oh
people do not like her the staff was
doing a dance over at the William with
Wendy Williams Show when she was out
she's a big pain in the ass I hate to
break the news to you honey good thing
you hurry back
I like low-key like really like Howard
Stern I don't know why ah shows like not
for me I think it's very sexual its
sexual and it's raunchy but I like
people even when I don't agree with
their opinion who just aren't afraid to
say what they think and I was just no
filter that's why I even like Knightley
pops so much not every episodes the
greatest episode but they're not afraid
to be mean yeah everyone is still like
Katy Perry eats a closed bag of chips on
American Idol it's just like she's being
cute yeah and uh nightly pop they're
like she's really weird yeah there's
something off there's something off yeah
no I like I returned him and his wife
baby so much yeah we're just looking out
here like and I think that's why people
miss Joan Rivers so much oh yeah every
time every red carpet someone could wear
a trash bag beautiful elegant steady way
because if you say it it's like bullying
it's just an ugly dress right oh did you
watch Project Runway no oh I have a lot
of thoughts on it and I'm sad you do
watch car the class on watch happens
live no I did not I was catching up on
River now whatever at the end of the
episode like she said she loves to bake
and she baked Andy that's like gorgeous
like butter cake and Andy was eating it
right out of the bowl and he dropped it
and it flipped over and the whole cake
fell on the floor it was very funny by
the way someone commented
let's see see hacia the mugshots of
felicity and lori won't come out because
they do not serve law enforcement
purposes there's an article in people
that what does that mean I don't know
that seems like a lie literally every
print every celebrity's one shots out
there and this seems like it would serve
law enforcement purposes yeah also it
served two purposes
most definitely back to when Ian Howard
this is so savage but I feel like that
also as much as this is like below the
belt it's really not they're just
calling out the obvious things like
breakfast saying that someone has gone
Hollywood isn't that much of an indigo
but they're both poking now it's like
the low-hanging fruit like I didn't fade
on my own show you know right it's radio
if you fainted no one will know
those are the obvious things like I
wouldn't be surprised if this is a PR
stunt because when's the last time we
talked about Howard Stern on this show
totally but like I feel like Howard
Stern doesn't need press like he is
constantly just relevant he has so many
listeners and like people [ __ ] diver I
know he doesn't need press but like I
wouldn't be sighs if this is just like
there's no hard feelings I feel like
because the two of them are so tough
they also have thick skin and it's like
what when he said saying that Howard
Serna in Hollywood I don't think hurts
his feeling is saying that Wendy
Williams feeding on her show is the
truth and I don't think that that hurts
my feelings no because she she talks a
lot of [ __ ] I think she can take a lot
of [ __ ] yeah but like that's Howard
Stern it's like why's this random woman
coming for me I'm gonna come for her
harder and I totally got that right but
it I think actually I wouldn't be
surprised if like they have dinner next
month you know and you're like we're
both at the top of our team they're
scary they're both us they're both scary
as [ __ ] like I would never want to be on
the receiving end of a rant from either
of them so there's a mutual love there
you know I know respect me respect
okay our fifth and final story in a
little bees and health news because I
just want to switch it up social media
has been linked to a rise in mental
health disorders and teens survey finds
young adults born after 1995 I think I
believe that is Gen Z are affecting more
mental health issues researchers point
to lack of sleep and the rise of social
media I totally believe that mental
health issues have risen significantly
over the last decade which I totally
believe and I feel like you see it every
day and the rise of digital media may be
one reason why according to a national
survey released Thursday the research
published by the American Psychological
Association found sharp increases in the
number of young adults and adolescents
who reported experience negative who
reported experiencing negative
psychological symptoms specifically in
those born in 1995 were later known as I
Gen never heard that before they're
making [ __ ]
cute cuz it's like the digital I think
yeah genre but Jen's II was camera I
think generation yeah I feel like Jen's
II should be now but the next gen should
be called i gen cuz then they'll be real
that's like I currently well so I
definitely believe this as someone okay
was born in 1900 incidentally the
greatest spike in symptoms occurred in
2011 around the same time social media
burst onto the scene right so like okay
I know I think I can I would consider
myself a part of this group I was born
in 1994 like I'm right there on the brim
and I never thought of myself as anyway
I thought I'd always had like very good
mental health like I'm just like I'm
cool like I'm chilling normal quote
unquote but like now I find myself
having terrible anxiety all related to
social media like what people think
about me like and it's definitely has
like such a it takes a toll on on like
your self-esteem and it's like I never
thought of myself as anyone who like
struggled with mental health like I've
been having crazy anxiety and I think it
really does it's all about this yeah for
you specifically
and the our job doesn't help that but
like no now it's like technically you're
stressing about social media but you're
also stressing about your job and is
that a common thing that people stress
about their job right so now it's like
not only is is my like livelihood
incumbent upon and being like accepted
on social media so now so I have the
normal like everyone wants to be liked I
want their pictures to be liked but now
my livelihood depends on it so it's like
if I do something wrong or if I say
something stupid on the toast like it
eats at me like for years yeah but I
think also like back in high school you
used to get like sad or anxious you know
you weren't invited to a party even have
plans this weekend people are gonna see
Monday what you did this weekend and you
didn't do anything
and I think now all of that is even more
high shoved in your face yes because
it's like no one even has to ask you now
it's like they've already made up their
mind about you based on your social
media I know when it's like you might
not have known that a couple people were
hanging out over the weekend in high
school but like now they're taking
pictures of it at us on Instagram and
snapchat so I definitely know that
everyone was hanging out without me my
suspicions were confirmed confirmed
quote we found a substantial increase in
major depression or suicidal thoughts
psychological distress and more
attempted suicides after 2010 versus the
mid-2000s and that increase was by far
the largest in adolescents and young
adults said lead author Jean twinge
author of the book I gen and professor
of psychology at San Diago University I
just learned that Sandy I feel so stupid
I just learned that San Diego is in the
south of California it's in Southern
California I thought it was stamped by
San Francisco in the north
I don't think about the location of the
sand thank you often to San Diego so I
think you just knew I'm in to send a
probe into Santiago you want to know how
I found out
total Bellas you know how they do a map
of where they're flying that's fun I was
like San Diego's down there that's
really funny so informative so inform
I've been loving total Bellas and by the
way I ship Peter crossing and Nikki
Bella so much really went on the cutest
date ever they were proud of they need
on the show through a publicist okay I
think he was like I well Bella I call
them both Bella I know Embry was like
Nikki you should go on a date and Nikki
was finally coming on today idea brie
was like I will set you up with a
publicist on a celebrity day because
it's hard to date normal people yeah
and so she had a few options and she
chose Peter from The Bachelor and the
whole family when he came to pick her up
they were like swooning over how cute he
was that's super cute they kept saying
he was tall which I think was a dig to
John Cena cuz he's like really short
sure like he's so tall he said I can't
believe they're not together like after
all but that they put us through like
I'm really upset about it and she's with
her Dancing with the Stars partner now
what's a certain jay-z with this charge
it's like out here making babies yeah I
mean when you dance with someone there's
just that chemistry I sound like Nikki
Bella no like I mean you're literally
like grinding crotches with someone like
how can you not want to have sex of them
right and everyone's like snatched a F
totally anyways back to the story these
trends are weak or non-existent among
adults 26 years and over I guess I'm
just on the I'm not one yeah no I guess
that's why I feel one day this way and
one day that way and over suggesting a
generational shift in mood disorders
instead of an overall increase across
all ages right so it's not social media
affecting everyone it's social media
affecting the young and impressionable
yeah I mean I'm young just not
impressionable I think this is really
sad me too and you can see it in the way
that like really young like fans
interact with like they're they're like
Hall Z's or they're Taylor Swift's like
the people they love like it's so much
more meaningful they're like you're like
save my life and I sometimes I'm like
you're so dramatic but no like their
mental health is so fragile because they
grew up in this [ __ ] up world that
like no Telstra it actually does save
lives Hulsey actually does save lives
totally you may feel like that's how
people like I feel like the Internet in
general has so many negatives and this
is one major one that no one's even
attempting to fix yet like what are we
going to do about this the internet also
has so many
positives and so does technology why you
watch those Microsoft commercials and
people are doing things that they can
never do you know those Verizon
commercials like people who are in the
army literally get to talk to their
husbands and wives like every day it's
incredible and the toast is one of those
things we are a technology company and I
and I don't know how much we contribute
to negative mental health but I think we
contribute a lot to the positive where
it's like Sharon's having a rough time
in their life and they know they can
count on the toast every day for an hour
a day to be distracted and to maybe even
sometimes ninety minutes you know
sometimes ninety minute and then if your
patreon number you got even more by the
way my anagram speaking of just like
your mental health in your head of
yourselves the podcast episode that we
did about my anagram test is gonna be up
today it was quite informative for me
yeah you know and now everything I'm
doing and saying on the show I'm
thinking this is because I'm this
personality yeah and don't you feel like
super vulnerable when like you're
opening up you're like deep personality
to the world it's like I'm a jealous
person now I have to tell you guys right
and I do say Who I am jealous of in life
you do yeah like I mean it's just like a
silly social media jealousy it was just
like this girl was so cute and has such
a fun job and has the best clothes and
best body and so pretty whoo oh yeah but
it's also like it's a jelly how did i
watch the episode it's a jealousy then
you have with her but it's also like you
like an admiration yet I think it's good
like I think also with the same question
of like who inspires you is the same
person if who are you tell us of totally
you like I'm well that's a quarry
question you should turn it like that
who are you jealous of oh my god I don't
know like someone whose career you're
like that's my dream career yeah Amy
Schumer no like because I feel like when
it comes to like female comics
everyone's like Amy Schumer and like I
love Amy Schumer I liked her a lot more
before I just like when she got to her
peak like I would have done it so
differently you know what I mean yeah
I'm also someone who just hates when
like entertainment becomes politicized
and she just like totally did a 360 Jim
Gaffigan
yeah I mean I don't know there's no one
out there because there's no one who's
like super digital but it's also like
traditional comic which is why I feel
like I'm a real trailblazers are in my
industry you make sure you are making my
own industry so there's people whole
mining it like there's people in the
digital space said I really admire like
the Olivia Campos like she just
absolutely kills it in terms of content
in terms of personality in terms of
collaborations like she kills it then
there's people in the comedy space that
I truly admire like
Joan Rivers even like weirdly enough the
more I've become a comic the more I have
a lot of respect for Kathy Griffin and I
know we like used to hate on her but
like she's actually low-key funny and I
don't know I I you takes a lot of [ __ ] I
take yeah I take a lot of the things we
said it back about her except when she
came for any comment like that's where I
draw the line yeah yeah that was a weird
time yeah when she made that video that
was weird but that was a dark place for
like she had a buzz cut like she was
just in a dark place
I don't know I just don't I haven't
thought about it I don't like look at
others I'm like oh it's like I'm too
self-involved like become competitive
with anyone you know yeah which speaks
to your personality type yeah a crazy
person who turned on such a morning
toast that episode will be up probably
this afternoon so if you're looking for
some afternoon content can I ask you
something I could speak me I'm just like
mental health and anxiety I do feel as
if a lot of like my mental state has to
do with my level of like tiredness like
that's awesome that's part of this study
and so I don't know where I heard this
or if I made it up that like the way you
feel during the day is based off the
amount of sleep you had from the night
before last
oh I don't know about that and so this
week I've been like really studying my
sleep you know well this survey sorry to
like keep her you know back to the
survey has a lot it's social media and
sleep and they affect each other the new
survey also found that young people are
not sleeping as much as previous
generations which also play a role in
the rise of mental health issues
sleep deprivation affects mood and is
associated with anxiety and depression
teenagers definitely use social media in
a way that affects their sleep they're
exposed to light right before bed and
that light exposure alone delays their
sleep by 30 minutes blue light it also
affects their social interactions with
others that is so interesting I try not
to use my phone in the dark because that
light keeps you up because your brain
thinks it's daytime but if it's so
bright so like not to get too gross but
like it's really bad just to be on your
phone directly before bed so by trying
to do something like in between laying
on my phone in bed and then go into
sleep so maybe like sex or something you
know like there's good activities in
between or TV but that TV also has that
blue light I mean like something I don't
want as where I play with Co I don't
think it's as destructive as your phone
me and then think that cuz we wear glass
above us she'd be like we're getting
like we're not getting the blue light no
you need to wear blue light glasses okay
and then you have to have a good night's
sleep well no so I got a new mattress
and that's also helped my night sleep me
and Ben are different when it comes to
like levels of softness and like he is
just like so adamant about of having a
rock-hard bed and he did for a while and
it definitely took a toll on my back so
we got a purple mattress
I have broker are you enjoying it I'm
enjoying it like it feels different
which is good I feel like every time I
wake up I'm like oh that was a different
sleep you know interesting it feels like
I used to be like so Restless like I
felt like I was up the whole night now I
just feel like I'm asleep and I wake up
tonight it's great yes I think that's
how it's supposed to be the purple
mattress feels different than anything
you've ever experienced because it uses
a brand new material that was developed
by an actual rocket scientist it was not
me it was a different rocket scientist
it's like a memory foam it's not like a
memory foam that we're used to the
purple mattress feels very unique
because it's both firm and soft at the
same time which is good for me and then
because when we were like mattress
shopping in a regular store he was like
lying on every bed it's like it's too
soft it's too soft and I laid on every
bed I was like it's too hard it's too
hard you're gonna love purple right now
our listeners will get a free purple
pillow with the purchase of a mattress
that's in addition to the great gifts
they're offering site-wide texts toast
to eight four eight eight eight the only
way to get the free pillow is detects
toast to eight four eight eight eight
that's tio ast two eight four eight
eight eight great I want to segue into
our it feels like a new segment but it's
one we've been doing for a while but we
took a brief break from but due to high
demand we have brought back to your
toasters dear toasters is our advice
segment if you email to your toasters at
gmail.com just maybe some of your
quandary x' some of your issues in the
life I like the weirder ones but you
know we'll take the regular bridesmaid
workplace drama types also speaking of
new segments I had an ad I want to run
it by the toasters because when I'm
picking the stories everyday there are
some headlines that are just like pure
garbage and it's like why is this news
so I'm thinking of a new segment we can
do it once a week even where I just
aggregate like the worst headlines of
the week that are just not like that
make no sense that make no sense and
it's like highlights what's wrong with
our world let me know if you want to
hear them like how Tom Arnold saw
Massimo a month ago at a party along
with a hundred other people totally okay
we keep it anonymous so don't worry you
can send us something
oh dear Claudia and Jackie I'm gonna try
to lay out all the details for you so
buckle in that died if they're my
boyfriend is stalking a woman I sign
them to Facebook on my computer the
other day I typically only ever use my
phone app I notice the people in my
recent searches were people I had never
heard of I was so confused until I
realized my boyfriend had sighted into
his facebook on my computer and it must
have been logged in for awhile without
ever me realizing once I realized this I
got
curious about who these people were in
his recent searches I began to dig a
little okay i snooped I couldn't help
but I was intrigued what it came to find
is that my boyfriend has been searching
for the same woman's profile on Facebook
every day sometimes twice a day he uses
he searches her name at any given time
of day 11 a.m. 12 p.m. 2:00 a.m. but
it's always looking for her profile this
has been happening for months maybe
years obviously I was curious so I
looked at her page she's a married woman
a mom in her 50s my boyfriend and I have
been dating for a year and we were both
are in our early 20s I'm not hurt or
jealous but just confused and baffled
and I thought it was an interesting
factoid that was well interesting why I
want some kind of explanation I have no
idea who this woman is and why he's
stalking her in social media but there
is no way I can bring this up to him
without giving myself away
why is he fascinated with this woman who
appears to be a standard mom thanks for
coming on this wild ride
sincerely disturbed Wow okay um you know
what I'm gonna say straight up ask him
immature for a year if it's bad news
bears you are good to get out of there
but um don't like just make assumptions
you never know what if he's like
secretly adopted and that's his real
birth mother and he's just wants to see
what she's like don't come at him with
an accusatory tone come at him with like
the customer he has to be like I want to
know what's going on your life I noticed
this it's interesting or you could do
the classic like you're hanging out you
open up your computer and be like yeah
be like oh is this your Facebook who's
Donna you know yeah but I think that
might he might lie if he knows if he
thinks it's you don't know the depth of
what's going on so just I would approach
him in a really non confrontational way
like me can feel comfortable comfortable
be like I love you if you guys say that
yet and I just noticed I mean I wasn't
snooping but something that kept coming
up that I'm just curious about is that
you're searching for this person like
who is she and he that don't come into
this if you think they're like having
sex you know yeah and not like if it
could be his mom like seriously like use
the tone that you would use if you saw
it as he was looking for his birth
mother like something just really like I
want to be there for you what's going on
not like do you have a thing for older
married women right good point good
point well I feel like there was some
sage advice
damn toasters this is labeled nepotism
but not the good kind first let me start
off by saying big fan of your work huge
I'm hoping this message finds you well
as I find myself in a bit of a pickle
this is a long story so bear with me I'm
a graphic designer in Detroit Michigan
at an ad agency that I started at
following my college graduation in 2018
the main reason I got this job was
because my aunt will call her Linda
you CA encinitas I think so ready like
it all comes back to ants right and I'm
one day I'll be a TTA job Linda used to
be a big PR talk of the town gal when I
was just itty bitty both me and my
sister who was just a few years older I
used to love when she would come babysit
us because she was this carefree
rock-and-roll aunt she's 40 years old
single has never had any kids so she
always joked that she was grooming us to
be her progenies prodigies oh my god
she's not a typical aunt no one is she's
the picturesque a is a typical Anne
she's like the classic fun aunt or so I
thought
when both my sister and I were
transitioning from high school to
college she decided to quit her job and
start her and marketing company she
quote/unquote hired my sister first as
an intern after only about a year they
completely entered all communication and
had a huge falling-out my family just
shoves under the rug and refused to
bring it up to either of them awkward
fast forward to the summer after my
freshman year of college she offered me
two internships one of the companies she
was working at to pay the bills and the
other at a company and at the other
being for her company that she'd that
had yet to take off so I guess she was
working two jobs I would have been dumb
to turn down the opportunity because
internships in college are huge however
during a real job things started to get
sketchy she would often pull me into her
office shut the door and make me work on
stuff for her company and there were
many times where I was tricked into
going on an errand for her where we
would be gone for three or four hours at
a work event for her company
this of course gave me a huge pit bet I
was measly I was a measly intern and she
was my aunt about halfway into the
summer Aunt Linda was fired from the
real company for reasons unknown and I
was offered to stay and complete my
internship where I worked for the next
two summers as well that's definitely
awkward fast-forward to the summer
before my senior year I was ready to
move on from the old company and tried
and failed at finding a new apartment
sorry a new employment after six weeks
of sitting around Aunt Linda reached out
that she couldn't get me another
internship at her new real job I was
skeptical because of her history but was
desperate so I took it when I finished
the internship I found out that she was
fired again still for reasons unknown I
freelance with them with them for the
remainder of my senior year and landed a
full-time position after I graduated and
it is where I currently work a huge
weight was lifted off my shoulder
because I thought I'd finally had a good
excuse to stop working for her company
on the side because this rail job is
more important however about a month ago
into the job
my supervisor not my true boss but who I
still report to and work with yay Mike
asked me to go to a work lunch and I
quickly agreed when we get to the
restaurant my aunt was there to join us
I was ambushed and told that she had
convinced my supervisor and a handsome
people at my real job that they were
going to quit the company and go work
for her oh my god and that I was
supposed to follow them my aunt from
what I learned is a horrible business
woman and it's clearly manipulating
these people into thinking that she has
a magical company where they've all can
build money success and creative freedom
but knowing her track record I knew it
was a fire festival in the making this
is not an Encinitas this is an aunt
McFarlane totally in present-day I
consistently have Mike pulling me in on
secret projects for Linda's company and
I feel a lot of pressure to comply
because I don't want to piss them off in
my real work environment and you can't
really tell your aunt to [ __ ] off
unfortunately the other major
pertinently is that my aunt still owes
me money for work I did for her in
August totaling about $600 I've seen her
at family events which are cold and
awkward and she always conveniently
forgets to check what do i do joy back
out and risk both relationships do I
tell everyone she's a sham think of an
advance from a loving toaster wow this
is really tough um your aunt sounds
crazy first of all she doesn't sound
like an Al Lucy whatsoever no and she
does not sound like an auntie just
because I would never have feel working
for me and like doing odd jobs ya know
it beats she's taking advantage of this
girl like their familiar relationship
and that this girl like needs my like
needs a job and needs connections and
whatever and it's like snitches eight
truly but sometimes in the workplace
snitches are and maybe you need to tell
your actual boss not the supervisor
who's working with the fake aunt the
fence HS yeah that there's this
underground thing going on like blow the
whole thing up from inside but don't
tell anyone it was you yeah yeah we're
like I don't know how does this happen
where people have jobs and then they
have fake jobs like right it's like I'm
watching Entourage and it's like all the
agents are gonna leave with already but
then like the boss finds out and then
they have to stay it's like to leave a
company it's like you can't be working
for this fake company while also being
employed at the real company you either
have to move or not or like if you are
it's like an intermittent period where
you're just like phasing out so it
should be over soon that if it's if they
intend to still work for two companies
you need to speak up I I think
especially because you know you don't
need to tell like the people who are
going to work for Aunt Linda because
like you don't need to be like really
that much of a traitor to your family
but just tell the person who needs to
know the person who can handle this yeah
have them do it so that you're not doing
it from your compromises your priority
is your main job so I would forego the
$600 like you're never going to get it
for go at Linda's company just focus on
your real
and how you can best benefit that cuz
that's the only thing that matters yeah
until the person in charge who is not
connected to Aunt Linda wow she's giving
answer bad name totally that hurts I
really want to move on to our third and
final dear toasters cuz it's it's quite
interesting ooh
it's called does my husband have a trust
fund oh and the picture from the Gmail
has a picture of assumingly the scroll
on her husband and I think yeah
sometimes I get oh it's like really yeah
they look you but anyone looks good
I just want to say I'm a new toaster I'm
loving it I've stopped taking phone
calls from my friends in the work units
that I can finish listening before I get
to where I'm going which is feet anyway
long story short my husband's grandpa
was apparently really rich in had all
this money put away for his grandkids
yeah me but then when he died my
husband's evil step grandma like cut
everyone out of the will I don't know
how it works but basically there isn't
any money at all left that's all the
background info here's a problem sounds
like an episode of American greed
immediately after I got married my new
father-in-law and I had a big fight he
was our realtor and I felt he's super
cheated on the money he was charging so
one weekend my father-in-law went out of
town and asked my husband and I the dog
said well my husband went golfing so I
went to go and let the dog so I wait my
husband went golfing so I went to go and
let the dog out with my mom okay it's
harder mom went to the dad's house to
let the dog out yeah
my mom and I started snooping in my
father-in-law's office to see what
exactly he made on the sale of my old
house and purchasing of the new one
while snooping okay that's fair she had
good it like she did feel he was sneaky
so it's not like she wasn't looking for
the trust fund you know no she she
wasn't just looking for anything she was
looking for something specific but still
like that's technically in a court of
law like you acquire dissemination
illegally he doesn't count while
snooping I found a letter for my
husband's grandpa's attorney it was
addressed to my husband and it said that
there was a trust set up for him bla bla
bla I freaked out and didn't know what
to do and got nervous so I shoved it
back in the file folder I got it from
why does my father-in-law have that in
the secret spot he let her say it's it's
the grandpa's attorney the rich grandpa
had died it says it's written to the
grandson her husband there is a trust
set up for you okay it's very black and
white okay
why does my thought father-in-law have
that in a secret spot why doesn't my
husband know about it I told him I saw
it when I got home oh good okay my
husband can't tell his father that I was
snooping through his Commission folders
and stumbled upon it do I dig further do
I just wish this is true do I get my
hopes up for nothing
not a gold digger but could be digging
okay well I was gonna say you have to
tell your husband immediately
right but she did she did okay so I
think here you tell your husband your
husband's lab to go through his dad's
things yeah so you tell your husband to
go you're he's looking for something
business-related and he finds the letter
and then your husband takes it to his
dad I was gonna say like maybe your
husband knows and like isn't telling you
but the fact that you write I'm like
it's like that's you know these I
thought families meet you meet you it's
you so now that he knows no this is
unethical now it's like his son is being
cheated out of his trust fund this and
now it's the sons problem you've did
your due diligence as a wife a wife's
job is to shove a man in the back and
push him forward you just got to get him
to where he needs to go and tell him
what to say now it's just a jersey the
man is the head but the right is the
neck you can't you can't come out
swinging and be like I found this letter
but your husband sure come yeah your
husband sure can sure should and then
you take it from there I also know for
next time just take a picture of the
letter just so you have proof cuz he
could destroy it yeah the letter but
they have the upper hand right now which
is that the father-in-law is in the dark
right I would get a picture of it and
just start talking yes and send your
hubs in there it's just we're Ellen
except this guy's so shady he just like
leaves this letter on his desk when his
daughter's coming over you know no waves
in his file she was going through his
files and it just seems like if you're a
guy with files like you just don't have
like that one piece of paper just like
lying right by it looks like the one
piece of paper that's like an
incriminating it's not just in your desk
like it's in like a safe you know behind
a photo this is like an episode of SVU
where like the father like definitely
kills the son and then like it's all
because of this you know you think so
but I don't want that to happen I'm just
saying this sounds like either I don't
know these don't sound like murders
people just greedy people yeah or maybe
the husband circumvents the father find
out who the grandpa's lawyer was and
take care of business you don't need the
dad
yeah but now it makes me think why would
the grandfather leave the money to the
grandson and not the grandfather's son
he's like skipped a generation
interesting I don't know maybe maybe
that's what the dad is singing that's
why he's pissy right like some of the
dad sounds like a shady guy maybe the
the the granddad knew and didn't want to
give it to him right this sounds like
honestly an episode of like a hallmark
movie no the Royal the princess a
hallmark movie that Lori Loughlin
unfortunately will not be sorry on
but the one the Netflix hallmark movie
royal Christmas where he finds like the
letter that he's the heir to the throne
II Christmas Prince yes a Christmas
friends even though he is adopted but
Bill and the dad wrote literally just a
letter that said he's my heir well from
that Melissa McCarthy movie could you
ever forgive me
we know that letters like that can
easily be falsified this is true we
didn't even talk about that movie we
talked to me seriously nothing to say it
was just like a horrible movie about a
bad person and a sad person and a story
not worth telling
I've watched even in the three episodes
of American green that I watched would
be better stories someone made a great
point did the girl ever find out about
him cashing in on the sale of her house
like oh right what you came there for is
he shady did you find what you came
there for I would like an update on this
story immediately it immediately okay if
you like I want to go for another 15
minutes like just so we can say we did
three 90-minute shows in a row but this
is 75 I know you do you want to talk
about Project Runway well Lillian
watched it I would love to hear your
thoughts oh I stopped watching it
because of the corruption oh yeah well
so what
what has justice for ChaCha just as for
ChaCha and also just like justice I just
find that like what Nina Garcia
considers to be like the most beautiful
like nine times out of ten isn't what I
agree with house Karlie Kloss she's
pretty good she was really cute on watch
happens live she's doing a good job like
she's really understanding her place and
that like this is how she said it a
million times I'm watch I was like this
is Heidi and Tim's baby like we're not
trying to step on their feet and they've
been really gracious with us they
thought their time was up and they sent
us flour it's like they made it seem
like it was really amicable that like
she's not coming for Heidi Klum and like
she yeah when they said when she sent
someone home I was so glad she didn't
say of your design right what did she
say thank you you may not leave the
runway she doesn't have like a
catchphrase no and I think that's good
you can take a Carly's cookie on the way
out yeah please code yourself out of
here here are my thoughts wait so is
there anyone who's like talented and
exciting yes Kove eed he's Indian he's
so cute his model he was
tailoring her and he didn't realize that
she was transgender and she was like I'm
so the model was like I'm so grateful to
be from the first ever transgender model
on Project Runway and he literally was
cries like you don't understand like I
grew up in India me and my boyfriend
like the people call the our neighbors
call the police on us like I totally get
what you're going through and it was
just like this amazing moment and his
heed the most stunning dress
he didn't make top three and I saw all
these ugly are the other ugly outfits
they're like with the feathers I
couldn't believe it and there were two
other outfits so with the annoying part
of the episode is like there's so many
people in the beginning so it's like 15
contestants you can't deny her you can't
highlight on everyone so they chose
specific people specifically two people
who were literally like couldn't so if
their life depended on like there were
two girls and Jackie one of the girls we
know you tell me we went to dinner with
a couple girls from the bathroom they
invited some of their friends and there
was this girl there Kavanagh
I remember her and then I'm looking at
her and she's on project one my
obviously she was one who got sent home
No
yeah but to be honest like so there were
two girls at the very bottom Kavanagh
like made something that was just plain
like it looked like forever21 crop top
black crop top skirt I mean black skirt
pencil skirt when it like it was
supposed to be inspired by Brandon
Maxwell's mom like it was this whole
thing so technically she made a dress
like she said it was just commercial
ugliness he's a lack of style and vision
the other girl
they gave everyone's dimensions the
other girl made a bodysuit for a girl
that was like a foot shorter than the
girl that she ended up getting and this
girl was really priding herself she was
like there's so many designers here who
don't know how to you know design for
curvy women and she got a curvy model
they drew out of Hattin this girl got
one so like she had an upper hand she
[ __ ] up the dimensions not only was
her thing so ugly even if it had turned
out right there was no way could have
been cute she she was touching it while
they were evaluating it and a piece fell
off well that makes sense because
they're made in 24 hours like they had
two days okay but still like it does
everyone else did it that's what I'm
saying it's like so not only was it ugly
and also with not structurally sound she
didn't know how to like fit a model
there was a it seemed like that but she
got to stay over Capital I kind of
understand that because as a designer
like it's hard I mean not that I'm a
designer whatsoever but uh doing a
forever 21 outfit I think is more
egregious than taking a chance doing
something crazy no but the chance it was
also a forever forever 21 bodysuit with
like little stripes on it looked like a
bathing suit actually from Target it was
horrible Wow
I just thought it was interesting that
they got to say just didn't want to send
home someone who dressed a curvy model
because then they maybe they they both
had the same issues and it's like well
she had you know they don't want it to
be the issue of I agree
but so it seems I mean that girl
Kavanagh like she seemed like fine but
she was definitely saying a lot of
things she was so obnoxious like Ben was
dying because they sleep in twin beds
and she was like I haven't slept on a
twin bed since I was in Europe when the
twin beds are pushed together to make a
king and Ben was like dying
she was very snotty and like the the
group loves the girl with the blue
bodysuit like the girl who [ __ ] up who
actually got saved like the group loved
her but when she came in as the girl who
won like everyone was screening nobody
really liked the other girl so it was
like a happy ending I guess um okay
maybe I will watch it it just was really
frustrating the last season that I
watched because cha-cha got sent home
week 1 and he was the only designer that
I was excited about and while I'm
excited that they're to diversify in
their models and I think it's really
important it also became a reality show
about the models and their stories and
their personalities also it is and it's
all the models felt about the clothes
I'm sorry I'm not in oh well Kavanaugh
like she was running so behind she the
models start sewing like she really they
were both they both neither of them
we're gonna win so it doesn't show
there's like where the last time I
watched Edie was becoming equally about
the models as it was about the designers
and I I would watch America's Next Top
Model if I'm interested in the model
story but so something that I feel like
is really unfair is that they get
different models so like someone has a
plus-size model someone has just like an
average normal build size model someone
as a super tall and it is really hard to
make clothes for different sizes and
some people specialize in skinny girl
clothes and some people specialize in
normal clothes so it's almost a not a
level playing field I agree with that I
do like I think I just wish they would
have all normal looking models like not
[ __ ] anorexic tiny like you could see
their bones and just like average-sized
girls were the boobs and curbs like like
Barbara Palvin like a fit model yeah
like it is right no it's like they
either should all be too skinny they
should all be average they should all be
curvy like but in the playing field
should be the same I couldn't agree more
it's not it's cuz it's not equal and
that's also not how the fashion industry
works you design something for a certain
fit and then you make different sizes of
it like I don't think they're there to
prove their creativity and their crafts
they're not like it's just another
wrench to throw a nun already very
difficult and they have more wrenches
now they're adding like social media so
everyone has to photograph their things
which I actually thought was rad is cute
and except the girl cam and I was like
oh my god my brands we only is a real
never using an iPhone well then your
brand's gonna suffer yes I was just
really snotty but I really like and then
they put all them on the Instagram that
people are gonna vote and the winner
gets to be sold on bravotv.com like
their outfit oh I love that because
sometimes there are things that I want
to buy there was a girl who won oh my
god her eye like she like I feel like
just based on that like she has to win
the whole thing like she was she and
then it's show her the girls who won the
the actual challenge they didn't show
her working on her station for one
second because she probably like just
not that interesting it's so annoying
that we only get to see that the people
who suffered well they always film
mostly the people who are going home to
like explain why they're going home um
there was a girl who want Project Runway
I think was like three seasons ago her
name was Aaron and it was like she was
straight out of design school she was
just like maybe 22 23 and she just had
the best clothes and it's like where can
i buy her clothes now it's right like
where is she
Christian Siriano who's using the Tim
Gunn he's Tim Gunn yeah you know I
thought it was weird that he's because
he's not a judge he's a mentor but bread
and Maxwell is a judge and if you like
between the two designers like they're
pretty equal like I thought it was just
weird I would say maybe even Christian
Siriano is more well-known than saying
maybe it's just based on their
personalities well toreano can go into
the room and pump people yes Brenda max
what can just judge Elaine well truth
who was former editor of Teen Vogue I'm
obsessed with her she had the most
insightful insight like everything she
said I'm like you're right that does
look like like everything she yeah I
love that it's back on Bravo it's like
they're trying a little too hard to have
their foot in everything I can't explain
it but it's good and there's some real
talent out there I'm keeping my eye out
for Kobe do well I like the aspect of
the social media part where it's like
does it because that is what fashion is
and sometimes really come in Brooklyn so
they were taking interesting photos no
that's cool that's very important yeah I
enjoyed it well great I caught up on
Riverdale last night very spooky stuff I
don't watch it I'm just I really don't
have time I just I love it oh my god in
Luke Perry was on the episode and now
the three episodes I watched she was
only really in one scene of one and it
was felt like seeing a ghost like right
and what he was saying was so Arabic and
it really like Zak and I were really
shook I'm check
anyways I have a lunch meeting I gotta
get to ya and love lunch meetings that's
all we God have an amazing weekend I'll
see a bunch of you boss teens at
Foxwoods there's a few tickets laughs
we're at like 94% sold so like if you
want to come grab a ticket we're gonna
be spending the weekend there hitting
the casino tables in the club it's gonna
be a good time we're taking a limousine
there I'm really excited we are taking a
limo I'm still working on it but like I
just tell me I run its limit so like
thanks for walking at my spot
um please needed to make sure I got a
seat going covered thanks for listening
to the morning toast the Millennial
morning shall we go live Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time on
YouTube we're also available as a
podcast anywhere you can listen to
podcasts iTunes Spotify stitcher radio
all that yet thank you guys so much for
being here thanks for being a toaster
and we'll we'll see you on Monday but
you I'm not here I have very duty
oh we got oh I gotta get their compost
okay boys the pants I'll be here on
Tuesday the points guys all ready aren't
you say so we don't need you oh okay
well I'll be serving my country
you